Euskadi, como Cataluña,
no está para perder el tiempo y me da la sensación
que en Cataluña
habéis estado 10 años perdiendo el tiempo
fruto de la ignación
de unos gobiernos que Han estado centrados
en los que ahora sí
hay cuestiones que a nadie le importa.
Si en Euskadi, en Cataluña,
el sentimiento
independentista está bajo mínimos en estos momentos,
es Gracias a que el partido socialista
aplica las políticas
que tiene que aplicar,
aplica el acuerdo y aplica el diálogo.
Y existe 1 cuestión
que sí me gustaría resaltar y que también compartimos
el partido socialista de Cataluña
y el partido socialista de Euskadi,
que es la responsabilidad.
Actuar con responsabilidad
y actuar con responsabilidad
significa dotar de estabilidad a las instituciones